gather round souls fans and let's learn
the basics of one of the most innovative
and challenging game series of the last
decade I'm Jeremy aka Jung list
Australian games critic and huge Dark
Souls fan and I'm Michael otherwise
known on youtube for my dark souls
videos as variety video the soul series
test the resolve of those who play it
and perhaps you're here because you feel
unequipped rest assured that after
watching this short video series you'll
have everything you need to tackle Dark
Souls 2 and that's whether you're a new
player or a veteran looking to see
what's changed we've chopped these
videos up into little bits so you can
just tackle the bit that you want to
know more about so see the description
below if you're new to Dark Souls you'll
want to watch these videos if you're a
veteran and you've been there done that
we have a section towards the end
specifically about what's new in Dark
Souls 2 shall we get started
absolutely
Dark Souls 2 is probably unlike any
other game you've played it has a
shallow underlying story for the casual
player but if you look just a bit deeper
you'll realize that there's a depth to
the law and the story in these games
which is absolutely staggering you will
lose everything
by gathering item descriptions and
talking to NPCs in the game world
eventually you'll piece together this
story that is partly your own there's no
proper way to experience the story in
the Dark Souls 2 and that's part of the
wonder of it but to get to that point
guys you're going to have to master the
combat and that's where we come in Oh
fool you no longer you'll lose
yourselves all of them over and over
again let's start out with what's on
your screen right here is your health
bar when you start Dark Souls 2 your
ability to heal is limited so every
little bit counts whenever you take
damage from enemy attacks environmental
traps or obstacles this bar depletes if
it reaches zero then you die
right below it is the stamina bar doing
a tax blocking a rolling all takes
stamina stamina regenerates quickly
however it regenerates slower whenever
your shield is raised you want to
practice being aware of these bars at
all times because they'll affect your
play stop low on health don't panic but
it's time to back off and find an
opportunity to heal if you're in a
situation you can back off from low on
stamina drop your shield so you can
regenerate because without it you won't
be able to block and you won't be able
to fight down in the bottom left you've
got your right hand weapon and left hand
weapons you can have three of each
accessible at any one time above is your
magic spells that you have with you and
below are your items you can cycle
between your weapons shields spells and
items by pushing in the corresponding
direction on your d-pad lastly and the
bottom right is the amount of souls you
have these are gained by killing enemies
and exploring
you can either spend them as currency or
use them to become more powerful and
level up we recommend you don't carry
around too many souls with you since you
run the risk of losing them all if you
die the class you starred as in Dark
Souls 2 is absolutely no guarantee of
where you'll end up the warrior may
become the holy cleric or the sorcerer
may forsake his books and become the
knight remember all your starting class
does is give you a small boost to the
stats you'll need for that playstyle but
before we get to stats we'll need to
explain where you level up and how you
actually do it back in majula you'll
find the first bonfire right near it
will be a woman named the Emerald Herald
you should have a chat with are you the
next one
or merely a pool of fate there of the
cart she provides you with your first
Estus flask your most treasured healing
item she also offers you the ability to
level up your character should you have
the souls to do so take this with you
may it easier journey
now let's talk more about you the
character stats in Dark Souls 2 can be a
lot to get your head around so we'll go
through them one by one on the left are
your 9 stats you can level up each time
you spend souls to level up a stat your
character level increases by one and the
amount of souls you need for the next
level increases as well on the right are
the attributes that increase as you
level up your character shown in blue
this should give you an idea of what
leveling up each stat does as you
increase your stats your weapons that
scale with stats will do more damage
different stats will also level up your
resistances to various magics and
various status effects like bleed or
poison damage different armors and
shields also carry with them their own
resistances to these elements and on the
other side of that coin certain enemies
are weak to specific elements for
example fleshy enemies are vulnerable to
bleed damage and heavily armored foes
don't have a good time with electricity
if you need help on the screen then
press select for a description but let's
go over the stats now vigor relates to
your health upgrade that and your health
bar will increase endurance is the same
thing for your stamina bar and vitality
relates to how much equipment you can
carry the less equipment you have on you
the faster you'll move and roll and the
less stamina will be used in combat
edging towards your maximum weight will
make you roll like this
the attunements dad governs how many
spells you can bring into battle but
also the speed at which they're cast
every build that uses spells should
invest in this stat strength is fairly
straightforward some weapons will become
more powerful the higher your strength
studies and these weapons are really
good at breaking enemy defenses through
sheer force and dexterity is similar
certain weapons will scale up in the
damage they do along with your dexterity
and these are usually finesse weapons
like bows or rapiers adaptability is a
new stat that increases your
survivability across situations you'll
become more agile in almost every
movement you make and you'll increase
your ability to resist toxins and
dangerous elements in the world do not
underestimate this step down the bottom
intelligence increases the power of your
sorceries and fire magic and similarly
faith increases the power of your
miracles lightning fire magic and dark
magic there's one other attribute we
want to talk about today and that's
poise poise essentially makes it so
there's less of a chance you'll be
interrupted by an enemy attack different
pieces of armor will contribute a
different poise rating and essentially
the higher this is the less the chance
you'll be interrupted while performing
your own attack the heavier your armor
the more poison will give but the slower
your character will be so you're going
to have to experiment try on different
armors and see if you prefer the heavy
character who tanks hits or the lighter
character who can't afford to get it
all weapons most spells and some armors
have stat requirements that must be met
before they can be wielded properly for
example here we have a great sword which
requires 28 strength and 10 dexterity
that's compared with this short sword
that requires 14 strength and 6
dexterity in the case of weapons -
handing effectively halves the stat
requirements so that great sword is
available to us even if we only have 14
strength on this note bear in mind that
souls games treat stats as more of a
means to an end try and get the stats
you need for the gear you want and after
that don't worry too much more about it
it's important to level up your avatar
in Dark Souls 2 but it's more important
to level up yourself as you venture
through the land of drangleic the souls
you collect from destroying enemies can
be used to trade for other items or to
imbue yourself with more power
should you die and trust me you're going
to die you will come back in a hollow
state dying again we'll further this
process along until you become
completely Hollow such is your curse but
at the point at which you died you will
leave a green blood stain in which the
souls you had on you are kept reach this
blood stain and touch it and you'll
regain your souls fail to reach it and
die again and they're lost forever if
that frightens you then you want to just
give up right now like I have the
bonfires that pepper the land are your
beacons of Hope once you like them the
bonfire acts as a checkpoint and is
where you will respawn upon death the
bonfires are linked to each other
allowing you to travel between them at
will but be warned resting at a bonfire
will also rest the world around you your
health and potions will be replenished
but all enemies will return in Dark
Souls 2 we see what permanent changes we
can make to the world before it's time
to sit by the fire continually dying
will make your character more and more
Hollow and you'll notice your
character's flesh wearing away more
importantly though your maximum health
will edge lower and lower every time you
die eventually stopping at 50% for
the undead dies it is never truly dead
but only one step closer to Halloween
not all undead or hollows but all
hollows were once Undead
but don't worry there's one way to
reduce this process by consuming the
human effigies you find throughout the
land they're rare so use them wisely
these restore your maximum health but
more importantly they restore your
humanity be careful out there
where's talk of unsavory bandits who
prey upon travelers like you see so
let's talk combat for newcomers to the
game it's important to realize that this
is not god of war this isn't a
button-mashing combat system you don't
swing first and ask questions later far
better to take a reactionary approach to
combat watch your enemies first you get
to know their attack patterns before you
commit mastering combat is a must in
this world so if you need a refresher
you can always check the in-game
tutorial but we'll start here with what
the buttons do think of the triggers as
your hands whatever you've got in your
right hand will be used by r1 and r2 and
the same goes for the left mostly people
have a weapon in their right hand for
this r1 is attack and r2 is strong
attack if you've got a shield in your
left hand l1 is to block and l2 is to
parry
now the face buttons we'll talk about
both ps3 and 360 controllers if you want
to carry a weapon in both hands press
triangle or Y this will enable you to do
more damage with the weapon however
attacks will take more stamina and take
longer if you want to carry two of the
same weapon you get a special benefit
hold down the triangle button while
holding both of these weapons and you'll
enter a special stance that allows you
to attack with both at once
to perform many actions in the world
like opening doors or resting at
bonfires press X for ps3 or a4 360 using
an item is square or X these are things
like swigging your estes or applying
weapon buffs down on the d-pad changes
which item is selected right changes
what's in your right hand left changes
what's in your left hand and up changes
which magic spell you have selected
we've deliberately left one button for
last and that's your roll button this is
circle or B and you'll find it very
important to roll in Dark Souls 2
there's a small window during your roll
when you're invincible to most attacks
which means if you time it right you can
use it to evade almost anything
holding down the roll button will make
you sprint and while sprinting you can
jump by pressing down on the left
thumbstick it's the only jump button in
the game use it to get to tough areas if
you press r1 while sprinting you'll also
do a sprint attack lastly by pressing
the roll button while standing you'll
perform a backwards hop useful for
avoiding quick attacks pressing down on
the right thumbstick will lock onto
enemies useful for making sure your
swings aim true note that now your
movement is relative to his position
this allows you to strafe in a circle
around your enemies if you find yourself
behind one oppresive r1 will do a
backstab maneuver for more damage press
r3 again to turn off the lock for
example when you need to run away you
can also change the enemy you are locked
onto by flicking the right stick to
cycle between enemies you also have a
guard break attack available to you
which is great against shield happy
enemies and this is accomplished with a
quick flick forward on the left stick
and r1 every part of combat revolves
around the weapon you use and that's
because weapons differ in more than just
stats different weapons have different
move sets and different classes of
weapon have different styles the most
effective builds are those built around
the weapon you use in Dark Souls 2 there
is something called weapon scaling where
weapons become stronger depending on
your stats for example some weapons
become much stronger the higher your
dexterity is and this degree of scaling
is visible here from best to worst
degree of scaling is s a b c d e you
should check this on every weapon in use
because some weapons may become more
powerful with scaling if you want to
compare weapons equipped one and look at
alternatives in your inventory ones with
higher damage output will have a blue
value here and ones with lower damage
output will show a different value in
red
but remember weapons are more than just
the damages they do it's about their
range their moveset
speed find a weapon that suits you
swords are good all round us with some
thrusting and some slashing attacks most
of the time both strength and dexterity
increase the damage effects of similar
equally as you can see here this sword
has a c' scaling in both strength and
dexterity axes and maces are more
strength based and after successive
attacks are better at wearing down your
opponent's guard this triggers a state
of weakness which you can capitalize on
by tapping r1 right in front of them
again the strength scaling of these
weapons are seen here other weapons like
those reviews and scimitar x' require a
bit more finesse and the damage you do
with these will scale as you increase
your dexterity level the wide horizontal
sweeps of the great weapons are perfect
for taking on multiple enemies at once
as you can probably tell these weapons
require a huge investment in strength to
wield properly but in the more
claustrophobic altercations you'd be
better off with a thrusting weapon like
a rapier or a spear these thrusting
weapons can also be used while holding
up your shield
there are also magical or blessed
weapons which scale up with intelligence
or faith respectively they supplement
the abilities of the sorcerer or the
cleric giving them a viable melee option
you'll also notice that weapons use
different amounts of stamina and each
has their own animation and time for
attacks and recovery periods it's
important to understand how long your
attack to take to execute and recover
because during this time you can't block
and you're vulnerable there's so much to
tell you but the most important thing we
can say is to be observant enemies have
their own move sets and styles if you're
observant you can take note of enemy
attack patterns learn the best method
for beating them even if it's through
trial and error for example this enemy
will always attack you after you hit him
with the shield up get behind him and
backstab him or break him down with a
guard break attack
try learning how to bait enemies into
attacking you so you can either block or
avoid their attacks and then retaliate
with your own watch the duration of
their attacks and look for openings and
make sure you can recover in time to be
able to block roll or evade him again do
you see what I mean you should be
keeping a little ennemy journal in your
head so you know how to deal with them
in the future
in general though enemies are vulnerable
to attack after they've finished
attacking many holo enemies are
especially vulnerable after they've
finished a flurry of attacks so block or
dodge then counter-attack with your
honor some weapons can also inflict
unique status ailments and the land of
drangleic is full of enemies that will
try to take you out using these more
subtle means if you see one of these
bars building up while being attacked
you should probably panic a little some
enemies have weapons specifically
designed to make you bleed and in that
situation if the bar fills you'll lose a
massive amount of health straightaway
and have limited stamina another ailment
is poison which can be inflicted in a
variety of ways if the poison bar
reaches full you'll slowly lose health
over a period of time until the poison
finishes or is cured
one can also be cursed in drangleic and
cursed items will damage your maximum
health as long as you're near them or
until you destroy them lastly and most
dangerously is the petrify meter if this
bar reaches full you'll be frozen as a
statue shown in other players worlds as
a stationary reminder not to be cursed
certain gear will better be able to
resist poisoning cursing bleeding and
petrification or you can try to avoid it
through sheer skill in combat Dark Souls
is harsh but fair you start the game
confused and weak because it won't
conform to your idea of what a video
game is but by overcoming adversity and
using persistence you can master combat
in Dark Souls 2 you can't survive
drangleic without mastering at least the
basics of melee combat but should you
choose your true power can come from the
various forms of sorceries miracles and
pyromancy for magic users spell castings
are limited and replenish at the bonfire
unless you find a consumable item to
replenish your spell uses as you raise
your attunement stat you'll be able to
cast more spells but let's get into the
difference between sorcerers and clerics
a sorcerers power comes from
intelligence and mainly deals with
either magical energy or fire you need
catalysts to cast these spells such as a
staff and these are held in your hand
and used like a weapon with r1 to cast
pyromancers require a pyromancy hand to
cast their fiery incantations clerics
are the holier magic users and their
power comes from faith their miracles
deal and holy energy and lightning and
are also associated with dark hex magic
instead of catalysts miracles are cast
with a blessed item such as a chime you
can increase your damage in magic by
upgrading your staff chime or pyromancy
hand just like you would with a melee
weapon
sometimes you'll buy spells from
merchants sometimes you'll find them
around the world of drank less nikolas
began
is told by gods we preserve their will
with law pray to their greatness and are
blessed in return and now you can have
this powerful but all magic users need
to level the attunement step which
governs how many spells you can bring
into battle it's up to you to decide how
much you'll need but raising your
attunement stat also raises the speed at
which you cast spells and you can bet
the fiends of drangleic won't let you
take your time not all problems in
drangleic can be solved by a sword or
board in fact you'll have to rely on the
various items to cover your weaknesses
and the most important of these is Estus
you begin the game with one charge of
this item but as you adventure through
the world you find Estus shards which
you can take to the Emerald Herald to
increase the capacity of your flats is
that a shard you here let me see it to
see light however faint it might be
burning sublime bone dust in the medulla
bonfire will make your Estus flask more
effective
life gems are another healing item
you'll find around the world these are
more finite and they only heal over time
but they do let you walk while using
them thrown items can be very handy such
as knives firebombs and witching urns
which do magical damage these items can
be locked onto enemies with our three to
make sure they hit through constant use
your held equipment will also degrade
and you can see the status of your
equipment and its own little health bar
right next to it this is replenished
when you rest at a bonfire but because
some pieces of equipment are harder than
others you might need to make use of
repair powder sold at the blacksmith by
rubbing resins on your weapon you can
imbue it with additional power pine
resin for example we'll add lightning
damage similarly you can increase your
resistance to these elements with burs
an orange burr for example will increase
fire resistance these are items you'll
either find through exploration or
through combat lights and illumination
play a huge role in Dark Souls 2 and
this is made possible by a new item you
might recognize it called the torch
torches can be found throughout the game
world they will burn for five minutes
once lit illuminating the darkness
around your character and aiding with
navigation in arid areas in many of
these areas you will find unlit brazzers
which you can light to provide a
permanent light source for future run
throughs making an area easier to
navigate but be warned if you hold the
torch in one hand that means you're
essentially sacrificing use of your
shield it's a toss-up between visibility
and going without protection how badly
do you fear the dark
and of course you won't want to neglect
rings in Dark Souls 2 Dark Souls 2 gives
the player the ability to wear four
rings at one time rings offer the
ability to cover your weaknesses for
example increasing HP increasing your
burden increasing physical or elemental
defense or perhaps even the amount of
damage you take from falling rings are a
great way to balance out your character
without even having to level up the key
here again is experimentation as soon as
you find a ring try it on and see how it
effects your play there are over 50
rings in Dark Souls 2 and since there's
only four ring slots this means you're
going to need to choose what you wear
and possibly when you wear it to face
the many challenges in the game from
time to time as you seek misery your
world will blend with others the
timelines and spaces of drangleic or
such that the journeys of others will
bleed into yours even if you're not of
the same land or time this can be both
beneficial and dangerous you'll come
across orange soap stones in your
travels which allow you to write
messages to others these messages will
permeate between worlds and can be used
to help or hinder fellow adventurers you
can rate messages you find up or down
you'll also see allusions of other
travelers from time to time this will
happen mostly around bonfires where
weary travelers rest and where you stand
others might see if you come across one
of their bloodstains you can touch it to
witness the last 10 seconds before they
die and perhaps avoid the same traps
they fell into white sine soap stones
forge an even stronger connection
between worlds by writing your sign
someone can summon you into their world
to engage in jolly cooperation you can
do the same thing if you're in human
form having used an effigy and not died
since doing so you can summon white
phantoms to assist you in boss battles
some of these are human and some of them
are NPCs you need to have met during the
game who will often leave their summon
signs shortly before a boss there are
also those who will invade your world
without wanting to help you you see
these as red phantoms on screen
and that means it's time for player
versus player combat defeating a player
in this way will get you a reward in the
form of souls
you'll be warned on screen when an
invader interrupts your exploration of
the world during Lake is an open world
and though some paths are easier than
others you should explore it in any way
you wish navigation in a Souls game is a
really important thing most levels loop
back on around themselves providing
shortcuts halfway through that allow you
to bypass difficult parts of the level
shortcuts usually consist of a physical
change to the world like unlocking a
gate or blowing up a wall these are
permanent changes to the world they act
as the equivalent of reaching a small
ledge you can rest on when climbing a
mountain allowing you to skip obstacles
already to reverse if you're clever
sometimes you might even find shortcuts
that drastically reduce the time it
takes to get to a boss sometimes the
boss will even come to you these
powerful tortured souls are not like the
bosses in most games they each have
something special about whether that
means taking advantage of multiplayer or
seeking you out before you reach your
full power
if you're going to beat those tougher
enemies you're going to need some
advanced combat skills and one of the
best to know is parrying keep in mind a
successful parry just knocks them back
you need to take a step forward and hit
r1 to perform the coup de gras if you're
holding a shield that isn't a great
shield you can parry an enemy right
before their attack hits you this will
trigger a vulnerable state in which you
can press a normal r1 attack to run them
through for high damage one of the most
important things to know is that
parrying has a bit of a window there's
just a little bit of time when you're
moving your shield into position so you
actually need to press the parry button
a little bit before the enemy attack is
about to hit you the amount of time this
takes can be reduced by raising your
adaptability staff
and it pays to focus on enemy animation
cues usually there will be a type of
tail before an enemy attack either the
way they move or a sound they make if
you expect the wrong attack you could be
baited into doing a roll or parry too
early so you might want to remember
specific things about them that tell you
which attack is to come your weapons and
armor can be upgraded with various
materials you'll find throughout your
journey you can make your armor take
more damage and you can make your
weapons do more damage if you like the
move said and feel or look of a weapon
or maybe the weight and look of your
armor perhaps you'll choose to upgrade
those rather than replace it you'll need
a blacksmith to do so and one can be
found right at the start of your journey
although you'll need to buy a key off a
local trader to get into his house to
upgrade your weapon at the blacksmith
you'll need souls and a metal called
tight Knight a shard of titanite will
upgrade most basic equipment after that
you'll need large titanite shards it
gets bigger from there beyond this there
is even the option to imbue weapons with
the powers of fire magic lightning and
darkness to do this you'll need to find
special corresponding stones and take
them to a blacksmith as you take out
some of the more powerful bosses and
collect their souls these two can be
used in the crafting process with the
right stone you can infuse your weapon
or shield with different powers after
which it's upgraded normally you can
infuse weapons with the power of magic
fire lightning or dark in which case the
weapon becomes more sensitive to your
relative stats you can give it poison
damage or bleed damage you can make the
weapon raw which means it does more raw
damage but pays less attention to your
stats enchanting it will make it do no
magic damage but scale with your
intelligence you can also make it more
mundane or revert it back to its
original state
if you infuse shields with these
elements instead of increasing damage
it'll increase their resistances
believe us when we say things will only
get tougher so make sure you're up to
the task and don't neglect the crafting
process throughout Dark Souls 2 you may
come across NPCs who ask you if you wish
to join their covenant these are
factions or groups that you can align
yourself with and they carry with them
unique effects you give something to
gain something that's the way humans
like it right it might be just the thing
you need some covenants have rules the
NPC will explain to you when you join
most covenants reward you for giving
their leader certain types of items will
require you to defend their area some
even involve different types of online
matchmaking in PvP combat look around
majula
and the corresponding areas to see what
covenants you can join make sure you
take part in their requested activities
to see what you can achieve if you need
help why not proclaim faith in the blue
sentinels when you face danger the blue
sentinels will come to your aid
if you've been watching this tutorial
series so far you'd know we've covered
everything from magic to crafting to
combat but this section at the end is
purely for people who know souls games
and for people who want to know what's
different in Dark Souls 2 and there are
some pretty big changes from software
loves to experiment with new ideas for
starters one NPC will level you up now
similar to the maiden and black from
demon souls you can find this NPC in the
starting area of majula close to the
bonfire
speaking of bonfires you'll be able to
warp between bonfires now right from the
start no Lord vessel necessary and
you'll need the extra help avoiding your
human form no longer protects you from
those wanting to invade your world
though some of the covenants might help
and dying now slowly decreases your
maximum hit points down to a minimum of
50% you can reverse this by using a
human effigy which reverses your
Halloween these are rarer than humanity
though so use them carefully Dark Souls
2 will allow far more diverse play stops
whereas before entire categories of
weapons were useless like axes or whips
you'll find a lot is viable in Dark
Souls 2 everything's here for a reason
build a character around bows and arrows
if you want which can now be used while
moving in combat you can now effectively
dual wield weapons shields can be
two-handed for extra damage mitigation
and if you desire you can even carry a
sword and shield left-handed the
adaptability stat is an important new
addition parrying will now knock your
opponent to the ground making them
vulnerable but you can do multiple
carries in succession when fighting
multiple enemies the choice is yours
whether or not follow through the little
post
it's worth noting that now lightning
magic is associated with faith and fire
magic is associated with faith also
intelligence certain enemies and
drangleic will be able to petrify you if
this meter builds up that's an instant
death now that we've explained much
about the world of Dark Souls 2 we'll
offer you some tips to help you get
through it don't worry we won't spoil
anything Dark Souls is very much about
exploration and learning how to overcome
the enemies and traps but we'll just
help you improve your skills so it all
won't seems so hard so here we go
starting with combat number 1 learn how
to bait enemy attacks moving into
striking range of enemies and quickly
moving back or striking enemies shield
when they're raised will often cause
them to launch into a combo of strikes
this is called baiting once the enemy
finishes their attack move set they will
be open to attack as they recover even
better you can learn to roll through one
of their combos and be able to go for
the backstab or heavy r2 attack for
maximum damage
remember nearly all enemy attacks can be
rolled through but this is only if you
get the timing right however be aware
that rolling consumes stamina so be sure
to focus on evasive movement as well as
this uses no stamina at all baiting is
one of the most important parts of
combat it allows you to become familiar
with an enemy's move sir and it also
helps you practice moving your character
around often through groups of multiple
enemies all without being hit
number two try to separate enemies in
combat you're always better off fighting
enemies one-on-one if you see two
enemies in the distance then move
towards one first and try to take one
out before the other to aid in this you
can use items like knives or the bow and
arrow or bolts and crossbows to hit the
first target which will draw him towards
you so you can finish him off alone
knives are excellent for this type of
combat for long distances use the bow
and arrow for instances where multiple
enemies are unavoidable use your skill
and maneuver them into tight corridors
or doorways where they can only attack
you one at a time
you can also bait the closest enemy and
quickly attack them before the other
enemies can get into range
remember not to be greedy as you swing
your weapon the enemy is recovering
number three most enemies function on a
distance based awareness system for
aggression this means you can inch
forward towards one enemy possibly not
alerting others nearby to your presence
as soon as enemies become aware of you
they will usually come to you to attack
unless you use ranged weapons like bows
or arrows or sorcery you can then
dispatch them far easier in a one-on-one
fashion number four have your shield up
only when necessary
holding your shield up slow stamina
recovery all melee combat and sorcery
uses stamina so you need as much of it
in combat as possible and learning the
animations of attacks of your enemies
you should become familiar with the fact
that you only need to block exactly when
you're being hit during combat I'll just
usually tap l1 to raise my shield in the
very small window of when I can be hit
which means my stamina is always
recovering as fast as it can
this makes a huge difference in combat
with multiple enemies or against bosses
who constantly attack number five
experiment with damage potential and
reduction of both weapons and armor all
weapons have set stats for how much
damage they do and you can check these
when browsing for weapons at the
blacksmith or any other dealer by
checking them in your menu when you find
one in the world find a balance between
the weapon with the most damage
potential and the one with the move set
you favor most personally I can't go
past the battle axe at the side of the
it has a great move set for r1 attacks
and r2 heavy attack a short recovery
time between attacks and can be upgraded
to do good levels of damage you might
like lighter weapons or maybe weapons
with a bit more reach
or maybe weapons that favor a dexterity
build however it's important to check
all equipment available to you and see
what suits you best okay now we can move
on to your character number one of high
importance to anyone new to Dark Souls
is leveling up whenever possible well
you have to warp back to majula leveling
means that your character can do more
damage and take less damage there's no
avoiding the fact that you are going to
get hit a lot and die in this game but
leveling your character up will help you
do this a lot less if you want to use
specific weapons be aware of their stat
requirements and level up accordingly
there's no real shame in starting
another game as well having realized
that you spent your souls the wrong way
or bought the wrong weapons or even
killed the wrong NPC there's also an
item you'll get early on called the soul
vessel which allows you to reallocate
your stats try to keep your equipment
load below 60% your equipment load is
the weight of your equipped gear as a
percentage of your maximum it only
includes items on your person not those
in your inventory that is selected
shields armor weapons and items at over
60% equipment load your character starts
to move slower and roll a lot slower
you're less maneuverable and more likely
to get hit and just because it's heavier
doesn't mean it's better compare the
weight of the armor in relation to its
ability to defend against physical and
magical attacks don't forget to level up
your stat responsible for load and also
where possible look for rings that
affect your load while some Dark Souls
players liked characters of stone I
always valued maneuverability and I
think it's always better to be faster
than your enemy number 3 in early parts
of the game it pays to upgrade your
armor this is for two reasons firstly
because it increases your physical
magical and elemental defenses almost to
the point of far better armor but it
also adds no weight to your load ratio
unlike stronger replacements if you're
going to get hit and you will get hit at
least I'm sure you take as little down
as possible a number for look for a 100%
damage reduction shield all shields have
percentage reduction for types of damage
and this is either physical or elemental
for example a 95 physical reduction
shield will mean you're still taking 5%
damage while blocking attacks you can't
always roll because of the need to
conserve stamina and among multiple
enemies you might roll out of one attack
into another so you really need to find
a shield to block 100% of damage
unfortunately these seem rarer in Dark
Souls 2 you can also upgrade your shield
just like your armor and this also helps
in its ability to protect you from
damage lastly a little bit about the
game world number one explore all areas
of the world look for invisible walls
hidden paths and areas that look like
they can't be accessed you may see a
soul resting in an area that looks out
of reach chances are that this soul or
item is something of extreme value if
you can rotate the camera right around
to see if you're missing anything above
or below you you never know what you'll
find
number 2 lock stones will usually unlock
rooms with items in them or activate
useful functions in the environment or
even could unlock whole new levels buy
them whenever you see them in an NPCs
shop
number three read item descriptions not
many people do this but the people that
do find it really rewarding it may have
some hidden messages or perhaps a
meaning that explains its usefulness or
perhaps some key to the law of drangleic
number four talk to all npcs in fact
make a nuisance of yourself by
exhausting their possible conversations
you may unlock some information you need
to proceed or you may even be given an
item ah yes I have not thanked you for
humoring me the other day this is for
you
of course I have no idea what it is also
it's just generally a good idea to buy
something from each and every NPC you
come across some may offer additional
information after you do so or maybe
even perform other services for you at
other locations that's everything to
bring you up to speed we left plenty for
you to discover on your own for more
information on covenants or crafting be
sure to skip back to that section of the
video well check out the Dark Souls 2
wiki the souls games are incredibly deep
and we won't know everything about them
until a few months or years after
release we hope all that helps
adventurers go seek misery yeah
you